and the new super welterweight champion
of the world Julian J
[Music]
first of all I want to say humbly laughs
I'm just so blessed this is your moment
you just told me you've worked for this
since you were four years old
assalamualaikum greenies a piece welcome
to the Deen show I'm Eddie your host and
we got Jay Williams j-rock coming up the
new world champion he's making sajdah
he's saying alhamdulillah and wishing us
all a blessed Ramadan let's get to know
this young brother here exclusively on
the Deen show
so lonely cool but it comes along how
you doing my brother I'm the law we got
connected yeah yeah yeah I can't see you
hold on let me get this hold on one
second there we go oh okay okay what's
up my brother
good how's everything in Philly
everything's good it's different now man
yeah different I'm dizzy laughs bless me
I can't be more happier probably I was
telling my life
how was Ramadan going this is good it's
really good it's really good
all right let's get right into it tell
me brother you you are you have these
belts you know three of these belts
around your around your body what do
they signify uh just hard work it's
blessings from Allah
because I do ask for this and I didn't
get it without when I when I wanted it
but when I when I didn't get it you know
I just I just practiced patience a
little bit longer you know and uh it
made my man get stronger and I just kept
being patient it kept making dua and
just trying to be the best person the
best Muslim I could be and I got blessed
with it and I got blessed with doing
them up from Ramadan so come to the lab
his blessed name Julian Williams were
here with Julian Rick Williams the new
Telus for the people now that's not
what's the title of these bills the new
WBA IBF and IBO world champion who at
the end when his hand was raised and
this is what got all of us excited is
that you didn't do a chest bump but you
did what Jesus did what the last and
final messenger did all of the greatest
men in history they humble themselves
they didn't go ahead and point to
themselves but they made what you did
says des they prostrate it on the ground
take us through that moment well just
like
like I said I always wanted like as
Muslims we supposed to keep myself in
the remembrance of Allah at all times
and that was literally the best moment
of my life and I was just so grateful
you know that Allah blessed me with this
with this wind on this particular night
and that's the only I couldn't take a
nothing else to do that's the only thing
to do we just take a law because the
bless that comes directly from below and
I was just I just mean me I can't even
explain it it's hard to explain well you
did the right thing that's that's what
we call the the prostration of
gratefulness and this is the greatest
thing that a human being can do and you
and you led by example hopefully many
others will follow in your lead because
this is a state of keeping oneself
humble because we know what arrogance
leads to absolutely to the Hellfire yeah
Wow so tell us now you you actually now
also at the end you said something you
know you said alhamdulillah this is
another we like on the Deen show and to
kind of bridge that gap of
misunderstanding it's kind of equivalent
to hallelujah it's like you're excluding
all thanks and praises to the one who
created you yeah so that that was that
was something amazing for us that really
like you know brought many of us we saw
you in tears it was bringing us to tears
from all over the world from Pakistan
Palestine I was just and I let me say
something right I didn't think that this
were like this what happened I didn't
like this is how I felt you know I mean
and I just as you say I didn't expect
for this honest to happen that for
everything to go viral you know I'm just
for me expressing how I feel and you
know just thankful and grateful to Allah
so uh something do you like me I'm just
I'm just blessed that everything that's
the thing that let me tell you brother
it's that nowadays it's no secret that
Islamophobia is at all-time high you
have so many Muslims being oppressed all
over the world
and to see somebody not shy away you got
so many people who are courageous
they're top fighters but now when it
comes to identifying you know we've got
a Muslim there apologetically Muslim you
were unapologetically Muslim on who are
surrounded and submitted to God and you
showed that I'm I'm farmer pani slant
I'm firm upon Islam and I'm proud to be
a Muslim and I'm not gonna I'm not going
to shy away from from my faith because
Allah has blessed me with so much you
know at least I can do and I'm not a
perfect Muslim and I still get blessed
with so many things so at least I could
do is is is is is is its praise the law
when it cuz he's the only person to be
praised that's the least I could do you
know I mean but I agree with you a lot
of Muslims are like you know a little
bit shy about about about their religion
but I'm not like that and I wasn't
raised to be like that so Marcia part
beautiful to hear tell us how much of an
impact well let me before I get to that
to tell us afterwards you actually
showed great respect for your opponent
you know for his family for his mother
talk to us about that is that this is
coming from from the teachings of of
your Dean of Islam yeah absolutely
because first place for the church your
mother you know and he's supposed to
keep you supposed to keep toss to your
family and I can tell he has a good
relationship with his family and more
importantly he's that he's a classy dude
we leaned up to the fight we didn't have
like no back-and-forth we didn't curse
each other out we just knew that you
know it's a sport you know I mean he had
great sportsmanship he's a classy guy
his family more important was was classy
as well and which was a reflection to
him so I just wanted you know think
tough with being such classy people and
his mother was classy as well and I want
to just thank her for being the bait a
decent woman
so was a towards a person I were trying
to like but because boxing is a brutal
sport you know I mean so I just want to
think I just want to take this family
him and his family for being such classy
people how is that in contrast when you
seen I'm sure you you've seen you know
some of the controversy where you see
people like Conor McGregor insulted
people's families country religion and
you know
versus what you know you showed respect
honor what are your views on that well I
think that uh everybody's different you
know I'm gonna judge nobody you know me
uh I've probably done some things in the
past maybe that publicly that I would it
take back so I just and then a lot of
times a lot of stuff is to set a fight
it is the business of the day and they
need to sell tickets to get people
interested in the fight that's just not
my way about I'm not gonna embarrass
myself I'm not gonna embarrass it's lab
you know trying to sell a fight you know
I mean so I think that's just not that's
just my veto now somebody else might do
something different you know uh I think
I mean teaches old it's just not my way
we got love for everybody everybody you
know makes mistakes that that's just the
human process we're all works in process
but but just being a good example now
for the young you've coming up showing
that you know through hard work and
dedication and reliance on your Creator
you know being humble great things can
happen and you can be an example for
those youth you know for people who are
who are struggling and striving and they
don't have a positive you know example
and they get lost into this world of
destruction that's right that's what I
hope to be because I want somebody to
look at me and say man if he did it I
could do it because I'm no different I
don't that I don't got superpowers I
just got I got a I got really good
dedication you know and and I'm a Muslim
and I make plenty to us and I have a
strong gay man that's it I don't have a
superpower you know something if
somebody look at me they're maybe both
do anything you know might not be trying
to everybody can be a boxer might try to
get to school or make it to be a fellow
player or be a doctor or nurse or
whatever you know I mean because it's
hard out here trying to accomplish
things
cuz if it was easy everybody would do it
you know I mean it's not easy so I want
to be the inspiration for people to keep
on going and keep on believing in
themselves so so what kind of message
would you get for the kids a lot of
times you've coming up in gangs and
drugs and you know all sorts of violence
and whatnot you know and then and then
they see they see someone like you
who actually you know you're committed
to your Deen to this way of life and and
you're trying to you know spread a
positive message I would say that youth
that's coming up - first of all don't be
a follower and find something that
you're really passionate about that you
really love you don't have to be squirts
everybody can't be a sports a
professional a professional athlete it
could be anything
fossum something that you really love
that you're really passionate about
chase your dream no matter what anyone
says and even if you fall down a few
times you have to get back to people who
believe in it if you really if it's
really your passion you got to keep
going just believing yourself and more
important believing a lot tell us tell
us brother what what kind of influence
did Malcolm X and Muhammad Ali have in
your life Malcolm X is a great
especially mahabali both of them stood
for something something big specially
that civil rights era
Muhammad Ali me it's funny I was talking
somebody about that before you before
you called me he's just like he's such a
great fighter inside the ring but I
loved him more fully there outside of
the room you know I stood up for black
people in America around those Psalms I
mean we were getting like brutalized you
know I mean and he put his own career in
line for the for the betterment of his
people you know and uh he just he just
didn't care the money wasn't a big deal
to him you know the fame wasn't a big
deal to him he just really loved his
people so much and man I wish I was just
got to shake his hand just one time he's
such a great dude such a great dude you
see now you got you got you got these
giants now who you like what you said
that it's not what he did inside the
ring but outside the ring that's what
you know made him you know he was a
humanitarian a person of peace you know
he was trying he was trying to represent
Islam in the best way and that's why
people remember him to this day and he's
a Muslim American Hero
- yes sir inshallah God willing you know
some some big shoes to fill
yeah do the best you can brother
best I can but Mia Miley is such a great
guy he's such a great guy
ha how do you when you're talking you
know with you know with the not yet
Muslims out there or no african-american
community Malcolm X he went back to his
roots you know Muhammad Ali and they
found that the African Americans you
know they have a deep-rooted history in
Islam they do they do a lot of people
don't understand that that the first
slaves that came to America was from
West Africa and they were Muslims a lot
of people are there they don't teach it
at a high school you know a lot of
people don't know that Christianity
didn't start getting getting beaten to
us until we got over to America the
first Muslim that came over to America
was from West Africa it may were only
100 percent most masha'Allah this is uh
there was one other other fighter out
there and when I when I when I saw you
make this such de and you know praise
the Creator instead of doing you know
the the traditional writers they point
they pop they do the chest bump you know
another another another brother out
there he has these three words and
inshallah we can we can we can all live
by them he say talks about let's see if
you know who his brother is also he says
stay humble stay connected to God stay
connected to prayer
you know our brother Habib oh yes our
brother Habib yeah and he has that Saint
he has that Saint stay humble stay
connected to prayer stay connected to
God if we can all do that as humans if
all humans can do that the world would
be a much better place wouldn't it he's
a great fighter to me he's a great
fighter inshallah if I come down we
could do this in person sometime yeah
absolutely
Oh sounds great I thank you but I love
you for the sake of your love may Allah
bless you keep you firm or that I mean
bless you I mean secular way yeah I'll
take up too long so it's very nice to
have this brother on the program
inshallah we can hook up again and he
shall we can take some lessons from
there for the other athletes who are out
there
keep it humble stay connected to the
Creator and stay connected with the
purpose of life of why you've been
created we'll see you next week tune in
every week to the Dean show where we
discuss these deep and relevant topics
that are there to enlighten you to
inspire you so you can grow we'll see
you next time until then subscribe right
now if you haven't peace be with you
assalamualaikum this is malik who my
brother habib ilex ah
how are you sir hamdullah you brought
your belt with you how's life now being
a champion with a belt coming like a lot
of attention a lot of money like like
crazy stuff a lot of crazy stuff and I
don't want this bill change me
what's the number-one most important
thing for you and should be for everyone
Habib number one important most
important cause stay connect with God
you always have to pray you always have
to stay humble and stay focused and stay
connected together Thank You hubby this
was fun nice having you but we're
looking forward to having you on the
real show the Deen show what do you say
brother let's do it just send me
location thank you so much guys
you